Welcome back!
Hello!
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome in.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
My cough is not good.
Not much better.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'm still feeling a little under the weather today.
Today, my... how do I say?
My nose was filled with so much ectoplasm earlier.
So, we'll just kind of see how far I get.
I definitely didn't want to miss stream though.
Firebug, thank you for the 10 gifts.
Ducky, thank you for the 5 gifts.
Thank you guys.
Filled with light.
I really wanted to play more DMC though.
So I apologize if I'm a little... not stupid.
Ducky, thank you for the 5 gifts.
Thank you.
Baby coffee.
Smart coughs?
Maybe.
Maybe, yeah.
Welcome back, DMC3.
Hope you feel better.
Thank you.
Thanks for the 3 bonds, Blade.
Teacup.
You're back to Teacup and NyanNyan.
Thanks for the 5 gifts, dude.
Oh my gosh.
So many messages.
Mike, welcome back.
Thank you.
Zidem, welcome back.
Thank you for stream on birthday.
Please don't sing.
Happy birth...
Are you sure you don't want me to?
Are you sure?
No song?
Happy birthday!
Mero, welcome to membership.
Thank you for the 20 gifts.
Thank you for the 10 gifts.
Queue down screen.
Dante, of course.
Dante is not here.
He's not here.
OK.
Let's get playing before I...
Before I... I don't know.
Ghosts don't die.
Before I reincarnate?
Is that possible?
Can I reincarnate from being sick?
I don't think so.
Shino, thank you for the 10 gifts.
Thank you so much.
Maybe I go into hibernation.
I don't know.
Turn down the sound a little bit.
Sometimes the sound in this game is all over the place.
I remember the...
The voices being so low, but...
Sweet dreams.
But the music is so loud.
Let's watch the opening.
We did this.
We were motivated.
Thanks, Kari!
It's real.
So cold.
Oh my god.
Dante is back.
RT Ronin, thanks for the 5 gifted.
True, true, true.
That's what I did.
That's exactly how the fight went.
That looks exactly like what I did.
True story.
True, true, true.
This is actually like recorded footage from my playthrough, you know?
Yeah, you remember?
But this...
But I got stabbed less.
I got stabbed...
That wasn't me though.
Only one was left standing.
Yeah, that part is exaggerated for a dramatic effect, you know?
Stop getting stabbed.
I did the stabbing.
Yeah.
Could you slick back your hair too?
I don't think I can do that.
I can make my bangs shorter.
I can make them longer.
Oh wait!
I can slick back my hair.
Maybe too much.
Too far?
I've been nominated for an Emmy for DMC cutscene performance.
Thank you.
It's Caillou?
What?
That's so... What?
That's so offensive.
It's funny because like...
When Caillou was doing her magic...
She showed me originally my face moving and I was bald.
And I was like, you know, maybe I'll have a bald toggle.
I'll like never use it.
Like ever.
And now I've used it like three times.
I even used it in my debut.
I don't like to use it though.
I don't want you guys to think of me as bald.
I don't want you guys to have that perception of me.
I want you to think of me as like a...
As like a dog with hair.
ViviCore thanks you for the five gifted.
You know?
Bald Minky extra cute.
No!
I'm here to get beat up by a cute ghost maid with a foam sword handing out flyers.
Yeah, let's just...
If you guys have seen that video...
Let's conjure all the energy of all the stabbings as me stabbing people not taking my flyer from my maid cafe.
Think of you as a 2P.
A 2P.
2P or not 2P.
I'll think of you as a cute instead.
No!
You're still cute when bald though.
But I mean bald is beautiful.
I say that.
So all the people who are bald in chat don't feel bad.
I'm just like you.
But with hair instead of bald.
But I can be bald.
Sometimes.
Aren't we all born bald?
I might have died bald.
And then grew my hair back.
I don't know.
Animation service station!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I have a full head of hair.
On most days.
Is the hair just ectoplasm?
I'm all ectoplasm baby!
I've got only ectoplasm.
Except my hair.
Which is a wig.
But it's also attached to me.
It's real.
A real wig.
I'm bald.
But not also bald.
I have hair.
It's my birthday.
I'm turning less of a bald baby.
Can you sing me happy birthday while bald?
MsFist is it really your birthday?
Is it really your birthday?
And you're asking for...
No.
Is it really?
Are you pulling my leg?
Are you joshing me?
Are you making a donkey out of me?
Is it really?
I'm going to go to your Twitter.
And I'm going to see if there's balloons.
MsFist.
There's no balloons!
You lied!
Red handed!
I almost got caught.
I almost went bald for you!
Fact check.
MsFist, you're pretty quiet now.
Twitter doesn't show balloons anymore.
That's a lie!
Wait, does it really?
I'm googling that too.
Oh wait.
I tweeted about you watching other Vtubers and you said it's your birthday.
Did you put it in the wrong day?
What was that?
Something just moved in my room.
Be gone!
Spirit!
That's not me!
My birthday was a few days ago.
Oh gosh.
Do you also want me to be bald Andrew?
Oh no.
Guys, I have to play the game.
Happy birthday to you!
To you!
Happy birthday bald MsFist!
No
more!
No more!
Rub her bald head for luck.
Oh no!
You have to pay me rorbs to rub my head.
So I can then convert it to blorbs.
Vin Diesel!
I found the balloon.
No!
Rorbs, rorbs.
Ok, I have to remember how to play the game.
It's been even longer than usual since I last played.
Was it really Christmas Eve, Eve?
Bald head of the Minto, what is your wisdom?
A blorb a day keeps the demons at bay.
Nice morb of a Vtuber, thank you.
Weepking, welcome to membership, thank you.
Hi Minto, hope you're feeling better.
Thank you!
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Minto DMC tradition, relearn the gameplay.
It's true.
Why does he have that look on his face?
So we are on chapter 10.
Chapter 10 baby.
We watched this, but we'll watch it again.
He's judging me.
I'm a little big.
Hope you're resting well.
Don't push yourself too hard.
Thank you.
We have to see the number.
Yell it out when you see it.
Yell number, number!
Wait, we are looking for 10, right?
10 number?
It was on the...was it on the book?
Does that woman really bother you?
Seize wax.
10.
Oh my god.
Knowing this, I thought you'd be more useful to me.
But I was wrong.
No wonder your attainment of power was incomplete.
He looks like a Ken doll.
His head is detachable.
You're an incomplete being as well.
Vergil's eyes are so...10!
Demon and human blood mingle in your veins.
His eyes are so big in anime.
That one feels a little more subtle.
I have no use for you.
The job.
Strengthen the silent bridge.
How much?
Let's see.
Let's check how much robes and everything I've got to purchase item.
26,000!
We could buy a blorb.
Wasn't I saving up for something?
I was saving up for...something.
And we just got Nevon.
Air raid.
It was probably Air Hike on Agni and Rudra.
I think it was.
Wait, but that's only 20,000.
What was I saving up for?
Vergil's such a weeb.
Did I get more stuff and I didn't realize?
More robes?
I think you got a lot at once.
Oh, whoops.
I have everything for this.
Is there anything I should buy for this new guy?
Is this new weapon pretty good?
Reverb shock.
Charge at the enemy and hit them with a powerful electric attack.
R, L, X.
No, but it's cool as fuck.
Air raid.
Air raid we had before.
In...I remember.
After transforming into demon form, you can spread out your ultra-powerful demon wings to float in the air for a limited time.
Press R, plus B, and midair.
Nevon is difficult to learn.
It's a tricky weapon.
It's very different from the other weapons.
Here, let's test it out then.
I just won't buy anything right now.
Oh, we're here.
Oh yes.
Oh, we went out this door.
There's a bunch of enemies on the other side.
Air raid might be good when you're like, man, I absolutely don't want to do platforming.
True.
So true.
Okay, wait.
Hold attack.
Okay, hold on.
I'm beatboxing.
Dante, I only know two notes.
You can hold the button.
That's what I tried doing before.
Oh!
Play free bird!
Record!
He's too cool for lessons.
He doesn't need them.
Okay.
Do stinger.
It won't let me.
Oh, like that?
Bam!
I just have to not put my weapon away because it takes a second for him to grab it out.
Wait, huh?
I didn't buy it.
So, I guess I don't have it.
Bing bong!
Look, I got the bamboo ship!
Oh, I have to buy it.
Okay.
We got a stone mask.
What is this?
Jojo's?
A mask of magic stone made by an ancient priest.
It is said he who dons it can walk on water.
I was gonna say, he who dons it works.
I'm now forced to give pre-birth as per the rules.
I don't think I have anything in the rules about that.
I'm about to go into labor.
What is happening?
What?
What's gonna happen?
Okay, I don't remember what I need that for.
So, I'm guessing I leave through here.
Is anybody...any baddies in here now?
Anyone took over?
No?
Okay.
And we just head back.
When
we are close...
Okay, I'm leaving.
I don't...
Where is the exit?
Money!
It's like right here?
Grab money.
Can we make a pregnancy joke?
What is happening?
Stop it!
Congrats on your collab with Toho.
Thank you!
Finally, something wholesome.
Thank you very much!
This is the one that we need to combo with it, right?
But like...
How am I supposed to...
Gosh, how am I supposed to...
How do you combo with this thing?
Sword Master?
What do you mean?
Oh, with Sword Master.
I think I don't know how to use this weapon.
Crazy!
Come on!
Just one more!
I got my blorb fragment.
This weapon scares me.
What's the quick change again?
Here we go.
Gotta go back to my sword.
For now.
Blorb attained.
Gosh, I can't...
I can't... I don't know.
Nice, there we go.
Okay, so maybe I go over into the middle.
Mint's not gonna read the notes, is she?
I don't know if I will.
What's this again?
Oh, the words restore the masks.
Sacred energy and the power to part oceans will be yours.
Oh, I used the mask.
Too good at this game, maybe?
Who's gonna appear?
It's LB for devil trigger, right?
Just so I remember.
Yeah, that's a little misleading.
Walk on water on my butt.
That's not at all what I just did.
I'm glowing for two now.
Glowing?
Like this?
What's this?
Neo generator.
A magic artifact able to supply power for an eternity.
It is used to power the main bridge.
What's gonna appear here?
And what's this guy?
What is that thing?
What is this thing?
Energy crisis solved.
Truly.
Hold LB and then release for DT explosion.
Softens enemies before you beat the shit out of them.
Oh my gosh, I thought I was about to fall.
Thank you.
The mission.
Um...
What was that now?
We went inside that guy.
At least we're fine.
Is it under file?
No.
We gotta go somewhere, baby.
Never got this far in TMC3 and I hate spoilers so I gotta leave.
Okay.
Have fun...
Finishing it.
And then maybe you'll come back.
Please come back.
Oops, that's not what I meant to do.
Oh, it's this area.
Can I get a hint, you guys?
If anybody knows.
Don't say no help.
Blue door.
Blue door?
The one I just went through.
All the way back.
Okay.
Where's the guy here?
I know there's a guy in here.
Where is he?
Oh.
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh my god.
What is this?
Be careful, Dante.
Be careful.
Where'd they go?
Are they coming back?
Oh.
Oh, now I get him from this side.
Okay, okay.
Get up, Dante.
We get him from this side now, buddy.
No, that's not what... Go after this guy.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
There we go, there we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, turn around.
Okay, we'll wait.
We'll wait for you.
I'm gonna go back to Trickster.
Oh my god.
Stop doing that, Dante, please.
No, stop, stop.
I know it's me, but also...
Taunt?
That's this button.
Oh, shoot.
I don't remember what button is taunt.
Oh my god, he's stinking.
Oh my god.
Is it hitting them through the thing?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
It doesn't even work.
Oh yeah, if I use Gunslinger on... Which side is it?
I don't remember.
Oh my god.
No!
Dante!
Can you perish, please?
Nope, that's not what I meant to do.
I meant to do maybe like that instead.
I don't think it's doing... I don't think it's taking damage.
I don't think it's taking damage.
It's so stinky.
Oh my god.
Alright, come back.
I'm just trying to get close to you!
Do they want me to use the guitar?
Where did it go?
Okay.
Oh wait.
This is so stupid.
I don't even think it hit.
That's so stupid.
No way.
Oh my god.
Maybe this guy.
Please!
Oh my god!
Just come here!
I think you're overthinking it.
I'm just not hitting him.
Finally.
Oh my god.
I just couldn't hit him.
Please don't make me do it again.
Okay.
Shoot.
Run!
Nice.
We got a gror.
Dodge!
Nice.
Run!
Where is the next guy?
Where is our next victim?
Grorbs!
Schmorgeborgs!
That was so awesome Dante!
You're so cool!
Wow!
That was so cool!
I'm just gonna keep going till I don't know where to go no more.
Is this a bridge?
What is this?
Do you need energy?
Or maybe...
Is this the guitar lady mission?
I did that one last week.
Not last time.
Not last week.
Last time I played I beat her.
Oh my goodness.
Camera angles.
I'm just gonna keep going.
Tell me when to stop.
Spiders!
Okay never mind.
I don't like the guitar.
It's too slow!
What the...Spiders are not good against this, right?
Shit, that's right.
No, no.
There's fire.
This guy is huge!
Holy moly.
I don't remember what's the...
I think that's dodge.
Ouch!
Nice!
Not nice!
Oh DT!
You're right!
Thank you!
You're so right!
DT baby!
DT!
Death to you!
And this way.
Little
babies!
Oh my god.
I hate these dang spiders.
No, that's not the gun I want.
Amigo!
No!
I had it for so little.
Oh gosh.
OK, we got one.
Where's my...Oh we did it.
OK.
Somehow.
Wrong gun!
Take that.
Kiwawa?
Where are you?
What did you say?
Oh.
Jingle starts playing.
We interrupt this regularly scheduled program to bring you...
Mintori Mirage dance...
Wait!
Did you upload it?
Jingle jangle!
Everybody go to Kiwawa's channel.
It's up here.
I did my best to dance Mirage with her.
And I didn't do it very well but...
I'll make a tweet too.
Yippee!
You're so cute.
No, you.
You're so cute and sexy.
How do you do it?
I hope you're not working too hard.
I hope you're able to rest while you're in Japan.
Kiwawa!
Hardly working.
I don't think that's true.
I learned it and like... I like basically just did it a bajillion times.
And like... I was like OK.
Record.
Just record and use the best take.
Oh gosh.
Yeah, surprise!
I'll retweet it later.
I will retweet it right now.
Surprise.
I was a surprise for the Mirage collab.
Oh my gosh.
You look so cute.
Wait, you haven't even tweeted it yet.
I didn't tweet it yet.
You didn't even tweet it!
OK, I'll do it later.
I'll do it later.
OK.
Alright, let's go back to my sword.
Rotating bridge.
Ah!
A bridge, you say.
That sounds like something we need to power.
Oh!
Looks like Don... Oh we are playing Blitzball now?
We are actually playing Blitzball?
He shoots, he scores!
Nice!
I did it!
I made it!
What's this?
Nothing.
Marble throughway.
No way, he's right here.
What?
Lady!
Woo!
Have fun.
Thank you Kyoro!
Why are you upset that he's dead?
Woohoo!
Dante is such a woohoo guy!
No!
His cape!
Thanks Jackie.
Thanks Kuro.
Scum.
Well, we have something in common.
I have a dysfunctional family too.
Scum.
The sad music.
I thought she was gonna shoot him lower.
No.
She wants to be alone with her feelings.
So he's really dead dead?
Yay!
We cleared a mission!
Oh...
We didn't get so great this time, but that's okay.
I haven't played the game in like two weeks.
That's me on the guitar.
No, the drums.
That's what I tell a sick joke.
What's the deal with washing machines?
Passing grade.
Yeah, C's get degrees everybody.
Eleven.
Oh, he's totally...I knew it.
He's alive.
Go towards the light.
Is he like back to normal?
Oh, she's shaking.
Oh...
Don't get too close.
He might sacrifice you too.
Virgil.
I don't...
Is he trying to get her to do his dirty work now?
I don't trust him.
Oh...
She's just got daddy issues a little bit.
Shut up, Baldi.
Sorry, Baldi is beautiful.
Womp womp.
He's not...this is not the last we're seeing of him.
I swear.
We're going to see this poopy head again.
I know it.
Oh, I missed the eleven.
I missed the eleven.
Where was it?
The blood.
Oh, it was the blood.
OK.
I did see his blood stain.
I was thinking it looked like very pink.
Revenge.
Give a guest from the past an adequate homecoming.
What does that mean?
Hey, I meant to help you and the Minto's are having fun.
I just saw the Chiara shirt with you.
You were so cute.
Thank you!
Oh gosh, I'm embarrassed now.
Thank you so much!
Wait, did she tweet it?
Now I can retweet it.
Mirage challenge is over.
But wait, there's more!
Oh my gosh, do you see her hand on my waist?
I'm so happy to have a 3D now that I can do things like this too.
A soup!
Thank you Merlin!
Just saw your dance with Wawa so cute.
Thank you!
Snuffer stuffer, I just saw your... Don't know, I'm so sorry, I'm late.
Long time listener, first time caller.
Hearing you cough makes me want to tell you that I've had the flu for the past three days.
We'll make it sister.
We'll make it sister!
I hope you feel better.
Get well soon.
The waist grip.
If you were to do the co-op mode of this game with someone, who would you collab with?
There's a co-op mode?
I feel like I know this actually.
Doesn't Bijuu really like this game?
This series?
It would be fun to play with someone who really likes it.
I don't know her very well though.
So like, don't go to her and be like, you should play with Mint or anything like that.
But it would be fun.
I don't know anyone, I don't know so many other people who really like it though.
I think...
I know Oimo really likes it too.
Yeah.
But yeah.
Gura, Bijuu and Iris all like it as far as I know.
I see, I see.
Anyone else too?
Doesn't have to be Hololive obviously.
Obviously, obviously.
Obviously.
Mint waist.
Rinne from Face Connect.
I see, I see, I see.
Cool.
Guys, what should we buy?
If anything.
Do we get the air hike for Agni and Rudra?
I really like using them.
Especially because I have the jet stream.
I don't need drive.
Air hike is great.
It would be nice to have it for more than one weapon, right?
You'd have to have those save files with all stuff unlocked for the co-op mode.
One for each character.
Oh, I see, I see.
The MC series is one of my favorite games of all time.
I'm glad you like it.
I'm glad you're happy I'm playing it.
Thank you.
Thanks for the super chat.
I don't know what to do.
Don't forget health and DT.
So true.
I never forget about a blorb.
But I do sometimes forget about the porb.
Maybe we... 4 out of 7.
This is 2 out of 6.
Maybe we should get a plorb.
Plorb?
Porb?
I like saying plorb.
It kind of implies that I'm saying plurple.
But, you know, it's fine.
More DT.
Okay, let's get more DT.
Yeah.
DT, baby, DT.
Okay.
Who am I fighting?
What's my...
Who's here?
Where?
Who's there?
Oh, you.
Oh, you!
Hold on, my money.
Easy.
Where am I going?
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
What's this?
Devilstar!
Here?
Perhaps?
This hallway looks...
That blood stain looks awfully suspicious.
Just gonna avoid that.
The gas!
The gas?
Oh, it's these things again.
Wait.
These are different things.
Just kidding.
Yeah!
The gas!
Oh, I thought I killed him, but I guess not.
I'm getting in the gas.
I'm getting gassed.
They're fast!
Yeah!
Yes!
Oh, more?
More?
I'm getting...They're laughing at me!
You little sucker!
I'm okay.
I breathed in the gas.
I breathed in the...
We must use our baroon.
It's time for a puzzle.
What's up there?
Come on, use your arms Dante!
What is this?
Three freakish looking faces are etched into the statue.
Now there's four of them.
Four freakish faces.
That's good alliteration.
Just photoshopped my face on all three of them.
The center face has tears of blood streaming down its face.
Okay.
I like the swinging chandelier, that's cool.
Sorry, just kidding.
Not hard to breathe, it's just...
How the hell do I get up there?
These are easily the most annoying enemies in the game.
They disappear when you face them, so you have to turn...
Ah, I see.
Oh, hello.
There we go.
I made it.
What's this?
No, I'm trying to investigate.
Okay.
Secret mission, maybe?
The statue looks too... happy.
Another one cries!
Three freakish faces are etched into the statue.
Two of the faces weep bloody tears.
I just wanted to destroy its happiness.
Instead, I was a genius.
Okay, good.
I assumed it was over here.
There we go.
Now they're all crying.
Yes.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
I hate this thing!
Oh,
my gosh.
Okay, I'm just gonna DT.
No, no, no.
You.
Please!
DT!
I'm wasting my DT on your stupid parry!
You bitch!
What's happening?
Big damage.
Not blast off.
I'm trying to take care of this stupid guy first.
Oh, damn.
I'm trying to dodge.
Oh, nice, nice.
We got him.
Okay.
Nope, nope.
Not blast off.
Where are you?
Not break down.
Okay.
Where is he?
Gassy?
Staryu?
Okay, so turn around!
Yeah,
we got a good amount of health back too.
Good, good, good.
Nice!
Gosh, I hate the Grim Reaper guy.
I have such trauma from the first chapter.
Holy...
The Temperance Wagon.
Does this break?
How do I get to you?
Just drop, Dante.
Oh, no!
Where am I going?
Hit the
other side.
Oh, gosh.
Do I have to not fall off this or something?
Because this is gonna...
Blast off!
Yeah!
Nice, nice.
Easy.
Why are you guys taking the train anyway?
Why are you taking the train?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If there were no other guys I would have just blasted him into oblivion.
Got him.
Oh my god.
I just...
How am I...Oh, he just leaves.
Okay, that's nice.
That's kind of nice, I suppose.
Oh, no!
Oh, shoot.
Blow him up.
We got him.
We got his ass.
That's fun.
Wait, but I wanted that grorb and there was also a rorb.
Hmm...
20,000 porb!
Love that squeaky.
No!
Oh my gosh.
I do have a devil star though.
I was trying to remember that.
You can go back?
Wait, I can?
Will I have to do the whole thing all over again?
You have to do the encounters again.
You can go back eventually.
Dante is pondering.
Dante, what should we do?
You have to fight them on the way back and then coming back again?
Okay.
Torture chamber.
I like the sound of that.
What's...
This might be my first super.
Wow, thank you!
B-tone player.
Hope you are doing well and recovering nicely.
I bet Chato is sending all the health to you.
Thank you!
Please describe what each orb face is feeling from their expression.
Save?
Is it a boss?
Oh, but if I die, I would have to just redo the whole chapter anyway.
This is a fight that can get hard.
But if I save, it doesn't matter.
There's checkpoints.
I'll do it just to make you guys feel better, but I truly think that's not how it works, right?
We'll do it on three.
Okay, what weapon should I use here?
What would be a good weapon to use for this fight?
Then...
The only thing saving does is save your orbs.
Okay, well, let's just go into it and see what happens.
He walks up to everything so nonchalantly.
Oh!
Agni and Ritra.
I wish I got an air hike then.
He knows my stink!
Speak up Dante, I can't hear you.
What's wrong with your head?
The stench of betrayal.
But you have to go after Vergil first, so I don't have to deal with you.
This guy looks hard.
Oh gosh.
Okay, he destroys those.
Oh god, okay.
This is a hard boss.
It says aim for the eye, but how do I aim for the eye?
Oh my god, I'm trying to dodge.
I died to this boss 54 times?
Oh my god.
I think I'm... This is where I get filtered real.
Sword Master.
Oh gosh, he hits hard.
Jump, jump, jump.
Okay, we got a little bit of him out.
Oh gosh, his range is insane.
Oh my gosh.
What was taunt again?
What was the button to taunt again?
I can't remember.
Minus, thank you.
Hmm.
Oh wait, no status.
Defile.
What do we have again for...
For uh...
I can never draw.
Jet stream was what?
Slash through enemies with increased speed.
So maybe I should get air hike then.
Maybe I should buy it here.
Just so I can have it because it is good to have to dodge I feel.
I think.
Air hike.
There goes all my robes.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, let's try it without it.
Let's try it without it.
We can just keep experimenting.
The potty.
You have to go to the ghosties room.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I tried.
Oh my god, he is so insane.
The guy looks like Teemu Godzilla.
Get out of here.
Move Dante.
But that's not what I meant to do.
I'm not doing very much damage to him am I?
Oh my god.
Oi!
I can't.
I don't know how to get out of here though.
I don't know how to get out of his attack.
I don't want to jump fast enough.
Nice.
What?
What is this?
Now you are a doll.
What's happening?
Oh my god.
I haven't moved there for some reason.
Do I hit those?
You can hit those back at him.
Okay, that's what I thought it was.
Holy...
What's the...
What is the move to roll again?
It's like...
I thought it was A, but I'm clearly not doing it.
Lock on.
Lock on and jump left.
Okay, okay, okay.
It was the lock on that I was missing.
Okay.
9 months preggers.
Congrats.
Also, thank you guys for...
telling me...
for helping me out with controls.
I ask literally every stream.
I'm like, how do I do this again?
I ask every time.
I appreciate it that you guys help me.
Every time.
Okay.
I think the trickster dodge is too slow for this guy, I'm not gonna lie.
Burst.
I think the trickster dodge is like...
Cause it's so...
It's so like...
Like there's that little bit of second...
Like...
There?
I can't move, you know?
Until I've completed the dodge.
So I think it's...
I think it's too slow.
You need to level it.
Ah...
Very intentional.
Happy stream, baby.
What should we call it?
What do you mean, it?
Jump?
Oh, wait.
No, why did I do that?
I was...
Jump?
Oh, gosh.
It's so hard sometimes.
Because it's also camera specific.
It's like whatever way he's facing.
Not whatever way the camera is.
Okay, okay, okay.
If you level trickster, it's way better.
I believe that.
Guys, I'm actually gonna go to the little ghost's room real quick.
If that's okay.
And then we'll do this.
So give me like one minute.
Everybody, stretch, get some water.
I'm not gonna be that long, but you know.
We are we.
I'm back.
I'm back, sorry.
Hold on, I gotta...
I gotta get to...
I think I'll name mine Minky.
Minky Jr. Did you wash your hands?
I always wash my hands, but I guess it doesn't matter now because I just blew my nose.
I gotta wash my hands again after I blew my nose.
This room is kind of ASMR, isn't it?
It's got like a nice little...
Crisp to it.
You wash your hands after blowing your nose?
You don't?
You don't wash your hands after blowing your nose?
You get your snot all over your hands and then you go and touch everything?
I wash right before I need to touch stuff.
Help is bursting out of my chest.
I also watched the new alien movie.
What was it called?
Alien Romulus?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How was it?
Was it good?
Honestly?
It's a bunch of teenagers.
And I was like, oh, maybe because they're children, they're gonna go easy on them.
I was like, oh, you know, I guess maybe...
Surely they won't kill the children.
I didn't like it.
Too many references?
That's fair.
Minto is spoiling?
What do you mean?
I'm not spoiling anything.
I'm not spoiling.
I didn't say anything.
Let's just...
And I also, I actually, I forgot until the part towards the end with the mutant baby.
With the baby.
Until then, I forgot that they, I had seen a behind the scenes where they, that was an actual actor.
With the, the baby is an actual actor.
Like, it's prosthetics obviously, but like, he's actually like super tall, and like, it's not, it wasn't like CGI.
Which is kind of insane.
The baby.
Will you be playing Miisai in the future?
How's your favorite thing in it?
Women.
I, I do want to play it, but I'm worried that like so many people have played it now that maybe people are sick of it.
That's impressive, TBH.
Right?
Actually, not a Renesmee situation.
No, he, he, like if you look him up, he's like a, he's like a, what's it called?
A basketball player maybe?
Haven't seen anyone's playthrough yet.
Me neither, I don't know anything about the game because I, I actually, I did buy it, I bought it before I left for Japan.
Because I was just like, oh, I really want to play this.
Seems interesting.
And then there's also a new Chilliz Art game that came out today?
Yesterday?
So, we'll maybe, we'll maybe do that.
I think the new Chilliz Art game, I heard, is actually quite scary.
Yukon Time!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Horror week, maybe.
You would like me side a lot, Edwager?
Am I saying it right?
Me side, my side, my side, my lady, my side.
Found baby on porch, please help!
It looks like you!
Massage.
Mint side.
I've been avoiding me side streams to watch Minky play.
I appreciate that.
Don't do that, you don't have to ever do that though.
The ugliest baby was the one made by CGI for Twilight.
I love Renesmee baby.
I love how ugly it is.
Say hello, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
I'm stuck!
Oh gosh!
I wish I could change the camera angle.
Sometimes!
I got his eye, I did.
Go me.
Turn into dog!
Okay, here.
Oh my god, it's so fast!
Nevermind.
I tried.
How are you... The heck are you...
Oh
my god, oh my god.
Get out of the... Get out of here Dante!
Dante!
I can't stand this man.
Oh my god, why is Dante suddenly...
I'm on 1 HP in a dream.
Oh my god.
I survived.
I dodged.
Why is he suddenly doing this move all of a sudden?
I'm trying to do the air jump whatever...
Airstrike!
Okay, I'm glad I didn't go to him.
1 HP in a dream!
Wait a second.
Do I have any save?
Or do I have any...
No.
I have a devil star.
Not worth.
I don't think so either.
I think if I had not 1 HP, I would use it.
But I'm gonna use it...
Now.
Oh my god.
Damn it.
NT,
NT.
NT, NT, NT.
Why?
Maybe it was because I was locked on him.
When I was doing...
Yeah, I needed to...
Wait.
I don't know.
Because usually I can jump in the air and it goes...
I wasn't on trickster, right?
No.
Oh, it's sword master move!
It's sword master mo...
Maybe if I'm like...
And then run.
And run.
And then...
Try throwing rebellion.
What do you mean?
What do you mean throwing?
Like using rebellion?
I don't know how to stop the things from coming at me.
That was one thing too.
Those were coming fast and I tried slashing at them, but...
Hmm...
Everybody, everybody...
Everybody has their own ways of beating it.
So all the chat is like conflicted.
It's okay.
I'll figure out my own way of playing it.
Okay now, first try, right?
I thought you were the ginger bird man.
Oh shit.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to get...
I'm not doing a very good job.
Get out of the way.
Oh, he still got me.
Son of a bitch.
Wait, I DT'd.
Maybe I didn't.
Get out of the way, Dante.
Oh, he still got me.
I'm already on phase 2?
Shut up.
This is messed up.
Don't tell me that.
No!
Okay...
It didn't work.
How am I supposed to get those?
Wait, I'm just gonna die and start over.
No!
You gotta swing early for those.
Okay, okay, okay.
Do stinger, but press the style button instead.
Wait.
Like...
That?
That's not stinger though.
I am holding forward.
Come
back to me!
So...
What do I...
When should I use this?
What people are trying to say is that if you do the move that throws your sword in front of you, it's easy to hit the cage as he tosses.
Okay, so I'd have to like...
Be...
I'd have to be like...
I'd have to be angled exactly.
Okay, let's try it with this.
Let's try it with this.
As soon as the cage falls down.
Holy moly!
Okay, it's kind of nice having air hug again, I'm not gonna lie.
I can't see you.
Oh my god.
I wish I had some eye frames there or something.
That'd be really nice.
Gosh.
I really messed that up.
Come here.
I'm so used to...
I tried to dodge.
Can't dodge at all.
You bitch!
Dante, you suck!
That was me though, I pressed the wrong thing.
I'm gonna die at the...
This is the worst round yet.
I'm not even gonna get to round 2 to even...
Try!
I see, I even still...
God.
I hate that you have to lock on to dodge.
I think that's such poop.
I hate that so much.
Okay, I think for this...
I think for the eye part...
And then...
I'll just have to be really good at switching fast, I suppose.
I'll just have to be really...
I don't agree about being locked on all the time though.
Because being locked on versus not being locked on are two different types of moveset.
So I think you have to like switch it around.
Just gotta lock in, yeah.
Okay.
Get out of here, get out of here.
Okay, nice.
Oops, oops, oops, oops, oops.
Oh, and I was trapped, I was trapped.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Oh, come on.
Oh, what the flip?
Seriously?
Oh gosh.
And
now...
Uh, taunt?
I messed up.
Okay.
Oh shoot.
Okay, time for big.
No, he's a dog!
Okay, uh...
Shit, what is this?
Wait, what was the...
Wait, wait, wait.
What's the move again?
Oh, what's the move again?
Sword...
Oh, I think I'm too late.
I switched to rebellion.
Lock on forward style button.
Okay.
Thank you.
I think I'm too late though.
I don't know how to dodge!
I did it!
And now there's a grorb!
Oh my god, and he hit me really bad.
I tried to just get the grorb, please!
Oh my god.
Oh,
no!
Holy sh...
Hi!
Oh
my god, can he see now?
I can't DT yet.
Oh gosh!
I can't believe I dodged that.
Ah!
Okay, that's fine.
Why are you able to see now?
Oh, I jumped too late.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, DT now.
Oh, come on.
Oh.
Jump!
I'm so scared, I'm shaking so bad!
Can you do that?
Can you do the thing again with the cages, you know?
Smash!
I thought I at least attacked him a little bit though.
Damn.
I don't know if he got me or...
Smash!
My legs... I mean my arms are jello right now.
Ah!
Shoot whenever far away.
You don't need to switch styles, just spam the shoot button.
Yeah, I need to remember that.
Even if it doesn't do much damage.
Or any damage.
Well, much damage, I can at least build DT.
Oh my gosh.
Second or third hardest fight?
What's the first hardest fight?
You'll see.
It's Virgil, isn't it?
Or is it the bald guy?
Okay.
At the very least, this is one of my favorite boss themes in the game.
So it's something to look forward to when I crash my face against him.
Ah...
Is getting Jetstream level 2...
Wait, which was this one again?
Slash through multiple enemies with increased speed.
Ah, maybe not.
Beowulf is a boss worth no silver bullet strategy.
There are tactics you can use, but in the end you just gotta brute force it.
Seems to be the case.
Wait, hold on.
I could buy more DT.
Wait, did I not buy this before?
Maybe I didn't.
Blorb, good too.
Blorb though.
Let's get the Blorb.
Oh!
I was like, did it add anything?
We're on a second level now.
Second bar.
Also consider DT explosion.
That's when you hold it down and then...
Can I even get to that though?
I'm so nervous.
I'm trying to get out of here!
It took out one of my things.
At least I have...
Oh, why did I do that?
Oh my god.
I meant to lock on.
My finger slipped.
Come on, get his ass.
Get his ass.
Oh my god.
Aw, damn it.
Maybe if I don't jump there it'll be better.
See, he gets me every time.
I try jumping back and he gets me.
Maybe I should...
That's not good.
Okay,
I'm gonna DT.
Nice.
Come on.
Is he about to...
Wait, wait, wait.
I almost had it, I almost had it.
This time.
No,
I got stuck.
That's not fair.
Did I grab it?
Ugh.
Jump, jump, jump!
Jump, jump, jump, jump!
Jump!
Jump, jump, jump!
AH!
Oh, shit, that's not where I want to be.
Jump!
Oh no, I jumped!
I jumped!
Oh, that's not the way.
Oh gosh.
Oh, that's not good.
This is not looking so hot guys.
As long as I can dodge!
Until I get more... Oh shit.
No!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I jumped!
I jumped.
I jumped for real.
Maybe I didn't take damage though.
Jump!
Not good.
Jump.
When does he do the crush?
Like the...
Cause I feel like that one's easiest to get far away from him.
That one's easiest to get far away from him and shoot so I can at least build up some DT.
Have you tried going bald?
You gotta hit him in the eye again.
Wait.
Bald.
Power up.
Literally malding?
Yeah, the guns are doing some damage.
They are chipping.
It's good.
The signature move is Kabedon to the shadow realm.
Alright, we'll bald buff.
We'll bald buff!
Ah!
Wrong button.
Maybe the bald took away my...
Why is Dante dabbing?
Okay, I feel self-conscious.
I don't wanna be like this anymore.
Okay.
I never learn.
Maybe I should... Okay.
Roll.
Roll there, Minto.
Maybe I should've...
Roll, roll, roll!
Roll!
I'm trying to chip away as much as I can.
So that I can...
DT and then get a good amount.
Before getting to...
Oh, shoot.
Before getting to second phase.
You know what I mean?
That was terrible.
Oh, that was terrible.
So I think this might be my last time to hit him!
I don't...
And now we DT.
Okay.
I don't know.
I imagine there was probably people...
See?
Oh no, now he's in second phase!
Oh shit.
I'm in trouble.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
I did it too early!
Yeah!
Two out of three!
Could be worse.
Oh, shoot!
Ah!
God.
Dang it.
Ah, shit!
Ah, shit.
Trying
to get...
Ah!
Oh my god.
Ah, fuck!
Shit.
Oh.
That was such a waste.
That was such a waste of DT.
Oh no!
Ah, shit!
I didn't realize.
Sparta!
What is this?
Got to phase three, but I immediately died.
Oh, it's the hardest attack ever.
Oh.
But we got to phase three!
Let's go.
Progress made.
Exactly.
I'm just... My arms are noodles right now.
For real.
That
was not what I wanted to do at all.
Come on.
Come on, man.
Okay, I am going to DT sooner than before though.
Okay, DT.
Oh, shit!
No!
Ah!
You jerk!
Oh, shit.
There's a grove over here, right?
Did I miss the grove?
I think I missed the grove.
Ah!
I think I missed it.
Sorry, I'm not talking much because I'm like concentrating so much.
Ah, shit!
You bastard!
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me right now?
I thought I could just run to avoid it.
This is so stupid.
How am I supposed to dodge this?
How am I supposed to dodge that?
Oh my god!
But hey, I learned and I applied what I learned into this fight.
Save DT for that attack.
Tank with DT or stay close.
Okay.
I still think Trickster...
Oh, maybe Trickster Dash will work.
I just have to...
Boom, boom, boom, boom!
Sheesh!
That was scary.
Sorry, I'm not talking so much because I'm like concentrating like heck.
The bald buff yielded results.
What?
Lookit, Dante is being Sonic the Hedgehog right now.
You have to tell us every input.
A, B, A, B, A, B, A, B, dash, A, B...
Jump, jump, jump, not that way, jump, not that way!
Okay.
Every time, baby.
Like clockwork.
Damn,
even dodging that didn't do so much though.
Come on, his eye is right there.
Like I'm 100% hitting his eye.
His eye is right there.
Did I grab them?
Oh shit, oh shit!
I couldn't jump again.
I couldn't jump, I was already in the air.
Oh, fuck you.
Stupid dog, stupid dog!
I only like dogs who protect my smile!
Oh shoot.
Shit, well actually that worked out.
Oh no, that worked out.
That worked out.
Okay, DT.
Oh wait, maybe not.
Oh shoot, I think I messed up.
Ah!
Ah, dang it, I pressed the wrong button!
Again?
What?
Wait!
Uh, is it, uh...
Wait, uh...
Wait, what?
What is going on?
Oh, damn.
Get me out of here.
Why are those things there?
The pillar, hiding behind the pillar does not work!
I was so close to...
To avoiding it.
Oh my god, I can't see.
That's evil.
What's happening?
I'm so close to being able to DT.
Damn camera!
I couldn't see anything!
I might need to go get some more water though.
If that's okay.
He was like, adding stuff...
The pillar is coming down?
That's new.
I think Beowulf missed the part where that's his problem.
I cheesed this boss fight by only shooting.
You are so strong.
Kuso running away.
Hey!
It's called strategic...
Strategic...
Retreat.
He misses the tackle.
You can punish with your swords.
I think...
Another...
Other stuff that I have to take into account...
Is not DTing.
I think...
Maybe next fight...
If my health is not bad...
And we get pretty far down...
I'll use the devil star.
So that I can DT to avoid some attacks.
Let me go get some water.
Before we fight him.
You will have some more...
Lava ASMR.
But I think...
I think I have my strategy...
Mostly down.
At least what works for me.
I think I just have to refine it.
I have to not panic.
I think what works for me...
Is working.
I just have to refine it.
So I'm getting there.
When things get too difficult...
Just remember shotgun trickster is always an option.
Shotgun trickster.
She will be hydrated.
I will be and you should be too.
Drink water.
Lava ASMR.
Give me one minute to kind of...
Shake off the noodles.
I'm shaking off the noodles.
You're doing real good vibes for me.
I had to change my control scheme...
To beat this boss.
Now I use that scheme for every DMC game.
He'll kick it's butt.
It's butt boss.
I believe.
Thank you Sparky.
I have to beat it or else we can't progress in the game.
I have to beat it.
You should hydrate now.
Thunder and lightning.
Thank you boss.
It's Friday.
Are you guys having a good Friday?
Are you guys ready for the...
Weekend, weekend.
Yes, beating it is guaranteed.
It's only a matter of when.
Exactly.
We will beat it.
Just eventually.
Just woke up I guess.
Good morning.
You know this boss was a prototype...
For Mr. X and Ari series.
Oh no way.
Wait pirate, it's your birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday pirate five.
Five.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Nice remix.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'm just...
I need a break.
I want to definitely beat it this time though.
I want to beat it this time even though I'm starting to get weak in the head.
Speed.
Remember you told me to actually try meeting girls to increase my chances at getting a girlfriend before 30?
I signed up for a few speed dating events the next few weeks.
I'm doing my part.
Speed dating.
Speed dating sounds so scary though.
You're so brave.
World's bravest wisp.
Oh my gosh.
I've seen like, sometimes conventions will have speed dating.
Slow dating is scary enough.
I'm rooting for you.
Just make sure you introduce the lucky lady to Minto and she has to approve of me.
If she doesn't approve, kick her out.
Leave room for Minto.
Agreed.
She has to become our girlfriend.
My tonsils hurt.
When I first got sick, I was like, oh my gosh, do I have strep throat?
I had like five pictures of the back of my mouth trying to make sure I didn't have a strep throat.
Because I was like, my throat hurts so bad.
You have no tonsils!
Did you get to eat ice cream after they got taken out?
I've always heard that if you get your tonsils taken out, you get to eat ice cream afterwards.
I had a popsicle.
No, just jello.
What?
We have Dr. Wisps in here.
Send the picture, we'll give you a diagnosis.
Where's your credentials?
I didn't get ice cream when I got mine.
No!
From Hey Arnold?
Is that not real?
I thought art reflected life.
Is that not what happens?
I believed that my entire life.
And afterlife.
I also thought that was real specifically because...
Are you telling me my afterlife is a lie?
Are you serious?
I'm crying right now.
Real tears.
Web of lies.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe Hey Arnold would lie to me like this.
Don't cry.
I'll never trust again.
What if we just gotcha the weapons?
That's not good.
Dante is getting real impatient with me.
Tonsils for ice cream isn't the best deal I've seen.
Wait, what do you mean?
Does your voice change after you get your tonsils taken out?
I never had to get my tonsils taken out or my wisdom teeth taken out.
Isn't that kind of crazy?
My mouth is huge.
I got my big buck tooth and also a thang.
My dentist pulled all four of my wisdom teeth in one go.
I guess my wisdom teeth never grew.
I don't think they can grow now as it goes.
Sometimes I reach back there and I try to dig to see if I can get them out.
I'll dig there and be like, what if I can find the tooth?
Are you doing it now?
No.
I'm just feeling it with my tongue.
I'm still very wise.
Yeah, exactly.
We have our wisdom.
It's in there somewhere.
I can't feel them.
I'm not ready!
You son of a gun.
And I'll shoot you with line two.
Oh, wrong button.
I wanted to taunt.
Well, I'm DT.
Okay, doggie.
This one goes above.
Garbs!
Grab the garbs!
I got them.
Ah, shit!
Oh, that's... whoopsie.
Oh my god.
That was close.
Oh, shoot.
Ah, no!
I wasn't out of the...
Out of the... what's it called?
I wasn't out of...
Okay, phase three.
Pushing mark.
Goes above my head.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Ah, shoot.
I think I'm gonna... oh.
Oh my god.
Wait.
No, I'm stuck!
I'm stuck!
This is messed up.
I'm losing it.
Oh, come on!
Are you for real?
I'm just gonna DT.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I thought I was still in DT mode.
No!
I
fumbled at the end.
I full hard fumbled at the end.
I full... that was so close though.
I think we can do it.
Okay.
That was such a good run.
Until I messed up.
Sorry.
Oops.
Oh my god.
Why can't I get any iframes there?
It's so messed up.
He hits me like literally two times in a row.
Oops.
Oh, come on.
That's not what I meant to
do.
Over my head.
Holy cannoli.
I meant to lock on and I'm such an idiot.
I jumped!
I pressed A!
I did!
You ass!
Oh my god.
Shoot.
I'm gonna... I tried to get out.
Ah.
That was close.
Oh my god.
I don't think I got a single hit in.
Damn it.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
No.
Grab that, please.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize I was not in DT anymore.
Fuck.
He hits so hard.
What?
You're just gonna turn into a dog in front of me.
This isn't the run, you guys.
This isn't it.
This isn't the run.
No!
Please.
Ah, fuck me.
Ah!
I didn't get as close as I was before though.
Oh shoot.
I can't avoid this attack.
Hold on.
Just kill me.
Just kill me, please.
I wanna redo.
Redo.
I wasn't feeling it.
This is the run.
If I'm not feeling it, I'm not feeling it.
You don't have to be like...
You lost so little health.
If I'm not feeling it, I'm not feeling it.
That's all.
Lucky.
She's not feeling it, Mr. Krabs.
Thank you, Peter!
What would your Minto trigger form look like?
Neat, but sexier.
That's not even fast.
I don't know if I just ate that or not.
I eat it every time.
I don't know how to dodge it.
I seriously don't.
I eat it every time.
Fuck you.
Seriously.
Goes up.
And...
Crush crab.
I don't know what the hell he's saying there.
Sounds like he's saying crush crab or...
Oh, damn.
Oh, no!
Come on!
Can you parry that, I wonder?
Probably, right?
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Wait, I DT'd!
I DT'd, though!
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh, fuck.
No!
Grurb!
I don't think I had enough DT, maybe.
What is this?
Crush crab.
That's mean.
I'm not throwing a little baby tantrum.
Oh my god!
No way!
That hit me!
Crush crab!
Please!
Devil star.
Devil star time!
Oh, please.
Can I get any hits in?
That's mean.
I knew using... I was like, I feel it.
I feel I can do it.
The devil star, I'll use it!
Oh, thank you for the hocus pocus!
Thank you!
Oh!
Cut me some slack!
And!
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, gosh.
Good evening, I just got home from my birthday dinner!
Moshi moshi!
Happy birthday!
Hold on, I'll sing happy birthday after this.
Look, it's the 11.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Moshi moshi toshi!
Happy birthday to you!
Hey, to the person that said, hey VOD watcher, skip two hours ahead...
You only have to skip an hour and 25...
Instead, eat that!
I got my medical degree from Science and Medicine University, or SCAMU for short.
Now, please allow me to look at your diseased throat.
It's not diseased!
I checked it myself.
Save!
Clear!
I'm so happy!
Thank you!
Congratulations on clearing!
I did it!
Thank you!
Ah!
Oh, the purple!
Oh no!
Speedify, thanks for 9 months!
I'll die!
You know?
If that's what it takes to shut you up, it bugs the crap out of me that someone talks more than I do.
Don't act so rashly, my boy.
I've got a doozy of a story for you.
But, if you snuff out my voice like that, I won't be able to tell it now, will I?
Oopsie.
Oops.
Mommy?
What's that?
It's sucking me!
Oh no, is this a timed?
Oh god, is this a timed mission?
Twelve!
Hunter and hunted.
And haunted.
Reclaim the bridge before the soul is lost forever.
The last cough session just really got me good.
If this is timed, then maybe I should be able to do it, and then end it there, maybe.
Sorry, it really got me.
It really hurt.
Maybe I'll go take some medicine.
Hurt my lungs.
So, let me try it though.
Let's try it.
Oh gosh.
The haywire neo-generator.
He who holds this broken device is eradicated and their soul is drained in exchange for power.
Okay, run!
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Where am I going?
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Faster, faster!
We have to defeat these guys anyway, right?
Oh, they gave us orbs.
Nice.
I'm trying to... I'm trying to... I'm trying to get you.
There we go.
Oh, look how much health we have.
Oh, shoot!
Ah, shoot!
Yeah!
Give me, give me orbs, please.
Orbs!
Thank you.
And... Yeah!
Oh, more.
Yeah!
What?
You still come here?
You are not wanted!
Oh my God, it hits my ass so good.
My ass is grass when this guy is around.
Nice!
Where am I going?
This way?
Oh, no time for you.
Sorry.
I'm like a little... I'm like a spider.
I'm so fast.
Do I go down there?
Wait, where do I go?
Up?
Up the stairs.
Up the big grorb.
Oh, come on!
What is it?
Oh, why am I doing that?
I'm so stupid.
Oh my God.
What am I using?
There we go.
I love stinger.
Not yet.
Hold on.
No!
No, let's not.
There we go.
Yep.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
Yummy, yummy grorb.
Stinger?
There we go.
Don't have time for you.
Sorry.
Anyway, run.
What the hell is... Oh my God.
Oh my God.
Warps for days.
Oh shoot.
Oh God.
Oh my God.
Please.
I can't see anything.
I can't see anything!
This damn camera!
I'm gonna have to defeat these guys if I wanna live, I think.
Oh my God, please!
Depth perception!
Oh my God.
I'm just gonna double jump it.
OK, OK, OK.
I'm gonna die.
I'm not gonna make it, you guys!
OK, wait.
This might be OK.
Oh, no.
I'm totally not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it!
Help!
A checkpoint!
Oh my God.
You said... Whoever said that there was a checkpoint?
Thank you.
Oh my God.
You saved me.
Nice.
No breakdown.
No time for breakdown.
Only stinger!
Oh my God.
Nice.
I think I got him.
Nice!
Stinger only run, baby!
Nice.
I'm running and I made it.
Maybe?
I think?
Yes!
Oh,
what the hell is this?
Vital star?
Uh...
I don't wanna touch that?
Or I do wanna touch that?
Oh!
It's the optional bo... Oh.
If I touch that, that's the... That's the juggler, right?
I get a bunch of red orbs.
I don't know.
I think I'm OK right now.
Wait, how much farther is this level?
I did what you asked me to do.
Oh, we were supposed to go to the basement, right?
Stop.
Stop, Onii-san.
Underground arena.
Is this the end?
Or... Please say yes.
Hades?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you.
AR scores.
Chicken race.
Haunts.
Wait!
Oh, are you kidding me?
Wait, wait.
I thought it was just gonna be a timed stage and then it would be the over.
That's...
I forgot this guy was here too.
Yes?
Oh my god.
What if I just run past him every time?
Oh, OK.
The doors...
Oh, he doesn't like that.
OK.
It's damaging him the tiniest amount.
Wait, so...
Sorry, horse.
What's happening?
What the hell?
Nevermind.
I can't tell if he's gonna stop or not.
The world!
Chicken.
There's ice!
OK, hold on.
For real, I'm gonna go get my cough medicine real quick.
So that I can at least have it in my system.
Give me one second.
Sorry, guys.
I...
I feel so bad that I've taken so many breaks this stream.
So I apologize.
Thank you!
Now I'm fighting a horse.
Oh, and he shoots rockets at me.
OK, that's cool.
OK.
Someone said ice earlier, maybe.
Again?
Oh my god.
Oh, I don't have airhike anymore.
God, I can't get up to his ass.
Where is he?
Oh, it's this shit again.
OK.
Oh, OK.
We're back to here.
Alright.
Get up on the horse's back!
Oh, that's damage.
Again.
What's this?
OK.
Oh, wait.
Ah, shoot.
That's not what I meant to do, but whatever works, works.
Oh my god!
Don't touch me.
Oh, shoot.
No.
Why
does that dude do such big damage?
Oh my god, I can't with me anymore.
Why do I keep pressing the wrong thing every time?
Sorry, I'm a little flustered right now.
OK.
Evil horse.
OK, we're doing this again.
I don't really know what the orbs are.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's so unfair!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Stupid horse!
You suck!
Thanks god.
But it looks like you're already better at the game than last time.
Thanks, Jake!
Oh wait, do I have to go through this?
Oh god, I start so far away.
I wanna redo, I wanna redo.
I wanna redo already.
Doesn't matter where I land.
You know I'm just gonna DC.
I've DC'd at the worst time.
At least I got some health back.
How did I do it before?
This is so, this is so...
Sorry, I'm getting a little tilted, not gonna lie.
And it's my own doing.
I'm mad at myself, I'm mad at myself.
This boss is lame, sorry Minto, it's okay.
I wouldn't, I think I'm just, because I'm not feeling well...
And I just...
I'll kill him though, we got this.
I have to wait for the cough medicine to kick in.
Okay, I didn't get hurt though, that's good, I guess.
Is he gonna stop here?
Yeah.
Nice.
That was so fast.
Just saw Minto dancing with Wawa, adorable.
Thank you!
Okay.
First chicken?
What do you mean, what does he mean by that?
What was the chicken?
Okay, I jumped up because I'm not sure how many hits I can get in...
Before, you know, before...
Damn.
I think
this does the most damage.
Nice.
Okay, alright, alright, alright, alright.
Nope.
That sucked.
Big damage!
Ah!
Asshole.
I want to get on the horse's back, but...
I don't know if I can!
Please!
So close!
Bitch.
No, no, no, no!
Ah, shit.
It's okay, we got him.
Easy.
At least, that guy is not very difficult at all, which is nice.
I just wasn't expecting a boss and another boss.
Get glued!
What is this?
Beowulf is mental.
I know.
Yeah, we ate that horse.
I was...I was...
Hungry.
We have Zawarudo power now?
Tokyo Dome.
Quicksilver.
Look at him go.
Special power that...
Let's go.
Don't change styles to Quicksilver by quickly pressing the right button twice.
My
rorbs.
Interesting.
It eats DT though.
Makes sense.
Virgil!
Virgil, my favorite brother.
Oh my god, this guy.
He's gonna take this dude out in one hit.
And it's gonna piss me off so much.
They are multiplying.
He quartered him.
Uh oh.
No.
Why does he get to keep him?
Why does he get to absorb his power but not me?
He gets to absorb the most difficult boss.
Guys, I think the pill...my cold pill is stuck in my throat.
So I actually...I'm just gonna end...
I'm actually just gonna end stream here.
Drink water.
I drank it all.
I have to go get more.
Okay, we're on save 3.
Save 3.
I was choking on it earlier when I went and took it.
I think it's stuck in my throat.
Izumi, happy birthday!
I'm sorry, I don't think I can sing for you right now.
But happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Yeah, chat, you sing.
You sing for Jimmy.
Okay.
Thank you everybody!
Sorry, today was...I had lots of fun despite not feeling well.
I hope you guys understand.
I did have a lot of fun and I really enjoyed playing Devil May Cry.
That's why I was like, oh, I'm more mission even after that hard guy, right?
So...
I had a lot of fun!
And hopefully I feel better soon.
I'm sorry that I'm sick and having to take a lot of breaks and having to go take medicine and having to cough!
Okay.
Otsumito!
Thank you everybody!
Bye bye!